[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
going to be Breaking Down House of the
Dragon season 2.
the official Instagram page for the show
has just dropped two big posts recently
yeah we also have a lot of big things to
talk about with some behind the scenes
videos the first video they posted was
the one that we just shown and this was
Then followed up with a post of the Iron
Throne this announced that season 2 was
in production and trust me we have a
hell of a lot to talk about tick tocks
being filled with several different
scenes that are currently being filmed
and throughout this video we're gonna be
going over what these scenes actually
show one of them is gonna be House of
the dragon's red wedding and I think
once it hits the internet things are
gonna implode now because of that
there's gonna be heavy spoilers ahead so
if you don't want anything ruined then
I'll recommend you check out now I know
you though mate your bloody love
spoilers so if you're a complete sicko
click the Subscribe button to make sure
you never miss an update you make me
sick and I bloody love you for it and
without the way thank you for clicking
this let's get in the house of the
Dragon season 2. The House of the Dragon
season 1 and with reneres and the Karis
being killed by Eamon
it was a hell of a big moment and it was
also the first blood in the dance of the
dragon's War sent out as an Envoy to
negotiate with either houses these were
supposed to have diplomatic immunity but
the deaths show that the greens weren't
playing around naranera was clearly
Furious come the end of season one and
it wasn't too long before she made her
first move with the help of Damon she
ended up hiring two assassins and these
were known as blood and cheese we've
done a big breakdown on the entire story
so I don't want to repeat everything but
the gist of it is that they snuck into
the red keep and went up to Alison's
room which is where they gagged and
bound her you see every night just
before Helena put her kids into bed
she'd take them up to say night night to
their Grandma but upon arriving she
found blood and cheese there as well
they grabbed her and her kids and said
that there would be an eye for an eye
and a son for his son blood and cheese
told Helena that she had to choose which
one of her children was gonna die to pay
off the debt and Helena uttered the name
Mela through gritted teeth and tears
however blood and cheese didn't end up
killing him and instead they turned the
blade over to her other Sonja Harris
killing him instead this eventually
drove Helena insane and it also caused a
major Rift between her and mailor he
knew that his mother had picked him to
die and therefore they had to live with
it being super awkward and the
Assassins fled and though they managed
to evade capture for a couple of days
blood was eventually caught with Joe
Harris's head in his bag under torture
he told them he'd been instructed to
take the head to Harren Hall and that my
zarya was behind the hiring everything
came out in the end though with the
connection to Damon and raniera and it
became clear that the blacks had been
behind it all now that takes us into the
first video in which you can hear an
era's new nickname and also see
something's going on here
[Music]
together
so yeah they're calling raniera raniera
the cruel this is a nickname that's
playing on Meg or the cruel who was the
third Targaryen King known as a tyrant
it clearly shows the kind of person that
the greens are painting her out to be
and when you see the kids coughing there
you can kind of tell why too now I think
that it was screenrant who put together
the entire story of tweets and videos
and they said that they think this is
the coffin that belongs to lucaris
however his body was never actually
found in the bark and there were even
some rumors that he'd got amnesia and
had gone on to live a happy life I don't
know their makers
oh so I think this is more likely the
young jaharis and there's a couple of
details here that seem to confirm that's
the case firstly the Knight announcing
Rainier the cruel doesn't seem like
something that they could do if it was
her son that died the Karis being killed
would have caused an uproar in the
Kingdom because many still saw an era as
being the rightful air even though aegon
was given a big public coronation this
was torn up by my lease and though this
was something that didn't happen in the
book they might have done it in this
season for a specific reason we'll talk
about that later on but Rainier may
still be incredibly popular amongst the
people of King's Landing unless the
greens have to twist The public's
mentality by putting it out there that
she's running around the cruel now if
this is the body of jiharis then that
would be the perfect way to do it and
marching his corpse through the streets
while shouting this would show how evil
she is I tell you mate I'm ready to take
the knee for renira the crew let's go
baby you son of a
now Beyond this we also have Alison and
Helena sat in the funeral Carriage we
have some photos of the pair together
and they're clearly dressed to show that
they're grieving they're not wearing
full on black because that would be like
wearing the football shirt of the team
that you absolutely hate but they are
wearing very dark green you can also
catch Kristen Cole riding right behind
them and it's probably because man wants
to be in a position where he can sniff
Alice in spots now the death of jahir
has caused a hell of a lot of issues in
the kingdom and rightly so it led to
some big battles that takes us into our
next clip in which we see this and yet
again spoiler alert this is good this is
gonna spoil the show for you mate
home
made
[Music]
thank you
so yeah this is clearly showing that
they're filming two different scenes at
once and obviously working on different
episodes at different times however this
is a major moment and in case you don't
know there's a big battle at rook's rest
in which melees in the Green's dragons
go head to head this happens in 129 AC
with renice flying out of the castle
which has been stormed by Kristen Cole's
forces it seemed like a pretty easy task
for her and her Dragon to carry out
however this was all a ruse to draw one
of reneres away both aegon and Eamon
derived on their dragons and fire in
Vegas and the three battled it out in
the skies above the location rather than
running though renice took them on head
to head but she didn't really stand a
chance against these two massive dragons
falling from the sky and burning each
other the three tumble to the ground
which led to them spiraling in a tornado
of fire before they impacted the Earth
only Eamonn and vegar came out of it
unharmed with renice's body being burned
so bad that they couldn't actually tell
if it was her or not aegon was badly
injured too with a is being so hot they
actually melted his armor into his skin
this left him unable to lead for some
time and in his stead Eamon took over I
am very excited for that as he's one of
my favorite characters and I think it
would be awesome to see him as being the
main green for season two now again the
greens wanted to spin public perception
in their favor after taking what could
be considered to be two L's back to back
to be fair melees in Raines being taken
out was pretty bad but if you look at
the green scent they actually had
dropped down in status quite a bit
season one showed how important the idea
of a melee was and they not only had
their King at that store but his
firstborn son was dead too so the air
had been changed which showed that they
weren't really the strong and stable
leaders that they claimed to be a cook
Coulda looked for someone stronger
now in order to show this weakness they
took the head of my lease dumped it on a
card and carried it through the city the
buck says this left the small Falcon
silence because no one had seen a dead
Dragon before we of course know that
Lots get wiped out during the dance of
the dragons and this is why Game of
Thrones doesn't have any in it early on
now going back to the big attack by
melee said the coronation this could
have been weaponized to show that the
greens are gonna get the head of anyone
who defies them I think it's crazy that
the two scenes that have come out show
what's coming in the aftermath of two
major moments and I think that both
these events have the power to break the
internet just blood and cheese alone is
gonna be the equivalent of the Red
Wedding and it's gonna Skyrocket the
series even further in my opinion now
the writers strike is currently ongoing
as well and this has affected a number
of different titles The Last of Us
season twos delayed the Mandalorian
season 4's delayed and we're gonna be
seeing a big knock on effect about a
year or so from now lots of shows aren't
gonna hit their release date and
production is stalled on a number of
different things however to the best of
my knowledge House of the Dragon won't
be affected and it has been said on
Twitter that everything's going ahead as
usual the scripts were said to be
completed before the strike began and
thus this should still hit its release
date however it probably won't allow for
things like rewriter and in the case of
stuff like Quantum of Solace which was
hit by the the writers strike a couple
of I think it was about a decade ago
maybe longer I remember them saying
stuff like Daniel Craig was having to
come up with lines on set and changed
the plot as they were making it now with
there being actual Source material to
base this off of I'm not sure how much
this will change but shows and movies
are always altering things on set which
they probably won't be able to fully
accomplish without writers there I'll of
course keep you up to date though and
I'm hoping that the writers strike gets
resolved soon because there's a lot of
things going on with it we actually talk
about it in depth on a brand new show
that me and Greg from real rejects have
launched which is called real spoilers
this is a weekly podcast in which we go
however all the news in the movie in TV
world and I've left a link to her on
screen right here it's on Spotify Amazon
and YouTube too and no it's not public
yet since you guys have sat until the
end of the video I'll put the links on
screen right now it's perfect but if
you're going for a walk or just sitting
and chilling and want something to
listen to so definitely go head over
there after this now if you want
something else to watch we have a big
breakdown of John Wick 4 on screen right
now too we go about all the Easter eggs
and hidden details in it and I guarantee
it's gonna have a lot of things that you
didn't catch I'm not calling you a kid
though mate I'm sure I'm sure you got
some of them but yeah definitely go head
over there because I've obsessed over
this movie now without the way huge
thank you for sitting through the video
I've been poor and I'll see you next
time take care peace